ton style j'avais rencontré sur
Instagram et au premier abord sur un
stage j'aimais bien son
feediens
tout ça ça me correspondait en fait donc
j'ai eu envie d'approfondir et ça va
approfondie ou non
au final non non
tu devais lui annoncer que tu étais
stripteaseuse toi dans la vie c'est ça
et force et ça a pas trop plu à Ilan en
fait lui il a pas accroché avec ça de ce
qu'on voit à la télé non il a pas trop
accroché mais de ce qu'on va pas à la
télé
il a accroché sans accrocher quoi
c'est-à-dire que il savait ce que
c'était ce domaine d'activité mais
apparemment ça lui plaisait pas trop et
après je l'ai fait aimer un petit peu
moi aussi très vite à poil non merci
ah mais je te jure c'est foutu tu te
prends au jeu tu as envie de te [__] à
poil partout
je comprends le cheminement je comprends
rien
moi je suis dans un milieu artistique
dans le monde de la nuit OK
tu es un peu cachée
[Musique]
et
dans le spectacle tu penses à quoi toi
strip-teaseuse
[Musique]
ça te dérange pas toi d'avoir une copine
strip-teaseuse
je suis
franchement pas du tout pour moi-même je
vois pas ma femme elle est
son strip-tease et moi je l'attends à la
maison genre
c'est pas possible
[Musique]
alors
au départ il était pas chaud Ilan et
puis bizarrement comme on dit il y a que
les imbéciles qui changent pas
il a direct deviné quoi
si tu viens habiller comme ça
c'est vrai voilà maintenant j'ai fait
rien à cacher
c'était avant que tu lui fasses une démo
que tu l'as fait une démo et finalement
il a bien accroché
et aussi des prestations dans les boîtes
de nuit de chaud de twerk il est chaud
de twerk oui je suis spécialisé dans le
twerk il faut que je te montre en plus
des choses et toi comme ça
[Musique]
en boîte de nuit c'est ça et sans la
robe parce qu'on te montre là
[Musique]
incroyable là c'est 15% c'est 15%
incroyable ça c'est pas mal je suis sur
une extra d'une scène
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien
[Applaudissements]
raccroché
au lit
les deux c'est un truc de fouet quand tu
as vu danser son son a fait qu'un tour
et je pense pas que son sang
très beau témoignage
et donc il y a eu un truc entre vous ou
pas non non
il était carrément chaud lui pour
poursuivre l'aventure
et toi tu devais donner une réponse
regarde c'est parti
le côté femme de moi enfin ma vraie
personnalité on n'était pas fait pour
pour s'entendre je pense tu l'as bien vu
et moi j'étais un peu déçue sur le fait
que tu changes d'avis avec un twerk tu
vois au final ben je me rends compte que
malheureusement tu sors pas du Lot tu
vois tu es un peu comme tous les autres
qui dès qu'ils ont une strip-tease en
face de donc tu vois les twerks les
choses les machins le sexisme
et je pense que tu correspond pas du
coup à la personne que je recherche
c'est chaud c'est chaud alors est-ce que
tu as trouvé l'amour depuis depuis non
non toujours pas aimons def
si si c'est un très beau garçon mais
alors est-ce que ça pourrait être ton
délire mais ça pourrait mais après moi
j'aime pas trop les trio
[Applaudissements]
tu es malade ou quoi
alors sache que il y a ici quelqu'un
autour de la table qui a vraiment
accroché avec toi
pour moi c'est une artiste incomprise en
fait le
contemporain et dénoncer beaucoup de
choses et pourquoi vous êtes une artiste
avec un grand arbre bravo merci
mon domaine d'activité il est très
incomprises
[Rires]